-That feels good, yes,
to have an audience.
-Feels good to have
an audience, finally.
-I'm so -- We're overdue.
I'm so happy that you're here.
You know I'm a big fan.
-No, I couldn't believe
I was invited again.
Thank you for inviting me.
-Yeah, no, we --
You're one of
the funniest actors I know.
But it's weird. I was just
talking about this earlier,
is that Molly Shannon
was here, as well,
and she does dramatic stuff,
and you're a dramatic actor
in this film.
-Yeah.
-Is it tough to be --
I mean, you're
an uber famous comedian --
to do -- to have people take you
seriously?
-That's what I want
to talk to you about,
because I've been doing comedy
my entire life
in Mexico and Latin America,
and this is one
of the few dramatic roles
that I've done in my career.
And -- But I love it,
and I think I'm going
to switch to drama
because -- because of that.
Have you noticed that a lot
of comedians, film comedians,
they switch at certain point
of their careers to drama
like Robin Williams --
-Ray Romano did a great job.
-Tom Hanks, Ray Romano,
you know, all these guys.
Jim Carrey.
And I think that it's because --
I hope you can relate to this.
It's because
people don't take us seriously.
[ Laughter ]
Not even our kids.
-No.
No, I am taking you seriously
right now.
-Thank you.
-I think that you are
really going to do this.
-You, but these guys don't.
-No, no, they don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Anything, anything,
anything we say,
they think it's a freaking joke.
[ Laughter ]
-Look.
-Yes, that's correct.
I know, but --
-Listen, listen, listen. Look.
-Yes. Yeah.
-Yellow chair.
[ Laughter ]
-Yellow chair got a --
-Whatever.
Say something, whatever.
-Yeah, I know
what you're talking about.
Sometimes you'll have
a conversation with someone,
and I'll go like, "I like this,"
and they go [Chuckles]
-Yeah, exactly.
-No, I actually do like it.
-I know, I know.
Funny story, let me tell you.
I was in Mexico City in a valet
parking lot waiting for my car,
and the valet parking attendant
brought my car,
and I saw a new scratch.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was like,
"Hey. This is a new scratch."
And he started laughing.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Bro, I'm serious.
This is new.
Who's going to pay for this?"
And he laughed even more.
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, you know,
"Please call the manager,"
and he laughed even more!
The angrier I got,
the more he laughed.
He thought I was
putting on an act.
-Yeah.
-So I just left with my scratch.
[ Laughter ]
-But let's talk
about "CODA," though.
You get an opportunity
to do something like this,
and how do you even
get the call?
-Uh, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's because
the director is Sian Heder,
an amazing female director,
and she -- She didn't know
I was a comedian.
She didn't know my background,
and she gave me the opportunity.
That's good.
-Yes.
-Imagine you're going to,
I don't know, China.
-Yeah.
-And another --
The director sees you --
-They don't know me
as a comedian.
-Exactly. And they're like,
"Oh, this guy is interesting.
I like his face."
-Yes.
-And they cast you.
[ Babbling indistinctly ]
And then you got the role.
It's amazing.
-Can you tell everyone
what the film is about?
-The film is about a CODA.
CODA means
a "child of deaf adults."
And Ruby, who's a CODA,
is the only hearing member
in her deaf family.
So she's been translating
for her family her entire life.
She's the only link between the
family and the hearing world.
So, one day, she joins
the choir club,
and she discovers
a talent for music.
And she finds herself torn
between pursuing her dreams
and the fear of abandoning
her family, basically.
-It's amazing, and you are --
-It's a really cool movie.
-It's a great movie.
And it's out now.
You can see it on Apple TV+.
-Yeah.
-Here's Eugenio Derbez
in "CODA."
Take a look.
-Why did you
run out of my class?
-I got scared.
-Of what? Other kids?
-Maybe.
Or maybe finding out
that I'm bad.
-Do you know what Bowie said
about Bob Dylan?
"A voice like sand and glue.
There are plenty of pretty
voices with nothing to say."
Do you have something to say?
-I think so.
-Good.
Then I'll see you in class...
Bob.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Eugenio Derbez!
"CODA" is in theaters
and streaming
on Apple TV+ right now.